hoje eu vou te mostrar uma maa que é
capaz de engolir inteiro canais do
YouTube e guspir conteúdos infinitos maa
que é capaz de ler dezenas de livros ao
mesmo tempo e você poder consultar eles
em tempo real o mayak tem praticamente
uma memória infinita quando a gente
começa a comparar com outras ias eu não
tô falando de nada menos que jenai e
para quem já me acompanha um tempo aqui
sabe que eu sou bem crítico do Google eu
acredito que o Google pecou em muita
coisa mas eu vou te dizer que aqui eu
acredito que eles estão acertando e vai
ser essa ia aqui que eu decidi usar
nesse vídeo para te mostrar como eu vou
pegar dezenas de Horas de conteúdos meus
para de uma forma preguiçosa extrair o
que meu time me pede há meses a minha
história Então nesse vídeo eu quero te
mostrar como é que eu vou extrair
conteúdos do YouTube dos meus
podcasts dos meus das minhas notações no
vou alimentar inteiramente o maa e a
partir disso eu vou conseguir extrair de
uma forma cronológica a minha história
para finalmente poder entregar pro meu
time se você quer entender mais como
explorar O jimini do Google e entender
como utilizar uma janel de contexto de 2
milhões de tokens então fica nesse vídeo
até o final porque eu vou te mostrar
como você fazer isso pra gente começar
aqui Alan como eu acesso o gemeni é pelo
site da Open se você acessar por aqui ah
você Tá acessando uma versão dele que
sinceramente eu não acho tão
interessante por quê Porque aqui você
pode mandar foto pode mandar vídeo ã
áudios mas eu gosto de acessar através
aqui ó do ai Studio então se você tá
vendo minha tela aí Ah você tá vendo que
eu estou aberto aqui é ai eu vou deixar
o link aqui embaixo ai studio.google.com
por Alan porque aqui você pode acessar
todos os modelos do Google sem custo
algum então você pode estar utilizando
aqui sem custo algum fazendo fitan
treinando modelo Aqui você pode fazer
várias coisas aqui dentro e ele é bem
interessante Então al O que é possível
fazer o que que é tão interessante que
você tá escolheu o Google eu até criei
uma imagem aqui pedi pro nosso amigo
clou aqui ó criar um gráfico para nós e
esse gráfico que eu quero que você
entenda o tamanho a diferença de tamanho
de uma LM paraa outra e é por isso que
eu utilizo as llms né utilizo mais do
que uma vou abrir aqui outra informação
para você que é uma planilha que eu tô
criando recentemente que eu vou
compartilhar com meus alunos mas eu vou
mostrar aqui para vocês nesse vídeo
também ah é uma planilha da empresa onde
a gente tá trabalhando mapeando aqui os
as llms que nós usamos né E por que nós
usamos elas você vai ver que não é só
uma ou duas a gente utiliza várias lms
diferentes porque Alan Por que que vocês
utilizam várias porque é a forma mais
rápida da a gente conseguir extrair o
melhor que existe na ia assim como
existem diferentes carros diferentes
modelos de celular e cada modelo de
celular vai ter aspectos diferentes as
llms estão se especializando de uma
forma diferente e cada uma vai ter uma
função melhor hoje existem se a gente
for abru aqui o site do hugan Face vou
até abrir com vocês Antes de mostrar
minha planilha vamos ver quantos modelos
tem ó existem hoje 1.2 milhões de
modelos como você está vendo aqui não
que todos esses modelos aqui são modelos
necessariamente como o chat GPT né
modelos de texto Transformers que são
modelos de texto para texto a gente tem
aqui como você tá vendo aqui ó vários
modelos diferentes um deles que está
aqui né em alta é um que eu quero até
inclusive trazer pro Canal aqui que é o
Deep seic de psic V3 é um modelo bem
interessante tá extremamente barato ele
é open source e muito interessante assim
para várias aplicações inclusive se for
ver aqui minha planilha ele tá aqui na
minha lista né ó essa aqui é minha
planilha Quais são as ias que você usa
hoje ó Hoje eu tô utilizando aqui ó CL
Cloud sonet 3.5 Cloud haik 3.5 GPT 4 o
GPT 4oin o Whisper para fazer
transcrições de áudio o Deep seic lama
3.3 gemeni 1.5 pro alguns outros gmis
que eu vou te mostrar agora também só
que só via ai Studio e assembly ai para
transcrições também de áudio então aqui
tá os valores fiz essa tabela aqui para
ter ali o máximo de janela de contexto
eu vou te explicar nesse vídeo O que que
é janela de contexto e porque que ela é
importante e aqui positivos negativos
quando a gente usa aqui na empresa cada
uma delas quem que é nível avançado e
tudo mais então Alan eu tenho que
entender como utilizar mais do que um
llm sim se você quer obter resultados
significativos se você quer conseguir
realmente extrair o máximo da i Porque
como você pode ver aqui nesse gráfico
que eu pedi para o clou criar nós temos
uma diferença muito grande entre os
modelos aqui você tá vendo em laranja é
o g PT 3.5 aquele que por muito tempo é
o que a maioria das pessoas utilizavam
no chat GPT porque ele estava disponível
no chat GPT de graça hoje nós estos aqui
o GPT 4 o o GPT 4oe tem 128.000 tokens
por muito tempo quando ele era só o
quatro ele era limitado a 32.000 ou seja
ele era um pouquinho maior só que esse
aqui Depois temos o cloud que de 100.000
passou para 200.000 tokens só que temos
agora o gemeni o gemeni com 2 milhões e
por que que tá dizendo agora o gemeni a
gente tem bastante tempo na verdade né
só que eles lançaram recentemente o
gemeni 2.0 que eu foi o que eu tava
mostrando aqui para vocês o 2.0 nesse
vídeo eu vou mostrar para vocês como eu
tenho utilizado ele porque ele tem uma
capacidade um reasoning né uma
capacidade de racionalização de
inteligência de extração de dados de
entendimento de dados muito melhor do
que 1.15 E por que que eu vou utilizar
pensa comigo o que foi a solicitação
aqui do meu time né eles gostariam de
ter a minha história de forma
cronológica para que eles possam
utilizar isso em conteúdos das redes
sociais quando vai escrever uma cópia de
um vídeo de vendas por exemplo né pegar
pontos da minha história ali que podem
fazer sentido ou na no momento que eu
for entrevistado Eles já terem um
documento que eles possam responder
sobre algum aspecto ou alguma coisa que
aconteceu e bom ao invés de eu pegar e
parar toda que ficar escrevendo por que
que então que eu não uso uma Iá para
extrair tudo isso e ainda por cima gravo
um vídeo pro YouTube aqui ensinando
vocês como fazer isso então é exatamente
o que eu vou fazer nesse vídeo eu vou
pegar conteúdos que eu sei que tem a
minha história vou jogar para uma ia que
possa conter muitas informações e então
conseguir extrair toda essa história
Alan por que que tu não usa o chat PT
ele tem 128.000 tokens bom um conteúdo
vamos ver o que que cabe dentro do
28.000 tokens eu pedi essa essa ajuda
aqui pr pra ia também aqui eu tô
utilizando o o1 da Open ai e eu pedi
para ela aqui ó me trazer o que que cabe
dentro de 2 milhões de tokens como vocês
podem ver aqui dentro de 2 milhões de
tokens cabem aqui ó cerca de 25 livros
cerca de 170 horas de 150 770 horas de
conteúdo falado e de 1000 a 1500 posts é
muita coisa agora deixa eu perguntar
para ele também aqui ó agora quanto cabe
em
128k que é o que o próprio o1 tem o o1
tem 128k de memória Alan como tu sabe
isso é só você digitar perguntar para ir
a pesquisar a internet ou digitar e nos
sites que você já vai encontrar quant tu
tem nessa minha planilha que eu criei
inclusive tá aqui ó a gelada de contexto
né tá aqui eu boto aqui a gelada de
contexto o máximo de saída também
algumas e t limitação inclusive de input
e isso é importante essas aqui nesse
caso não tem
Ah mas é importante você saber isso via
pi eu tô dizendo né O que a gente vai
utilizar aqui é via o chatbox que é o a
a plataforma de chat dessas plataformas
nelas tem limitações sim viu ah se eu
não me engano o chat PT ele aceita oit
1000 tokens de entrada de input ou seja
se você mandar mais do que isso ele vai
cortar e o modelo o1 64k de entrada
agora vamos ver o que aconteceu aqui
existem ó 128k daria aproximadamente um
a dois
livros cerca de 9 horas de conteúdo
falado e cerca de 96 posts Olha a
diferença ela é brutal é por isso que eu
pedi para ele desenhar aqui para nós
porque fica muito mais fácil ver
visualmente né a diferença olha só a
diferença do Cloud pro dimen em termos
de conteúdo Alan Por que que isso é
importante porque se eu pegar e mandar
tanto conteúdo quanto eu tenho aqui para
o chat IPT processar por exemplo se eu
abro aqui a janela do chat PT né abro
aqui a janela do chat PT como você tá
vendo aqui e começo a pedir para ele H
processar os meus dados vai chegar o
momento que ele vai começar a esquecer o
que ele tava
tratando o que eu poderia fazer aqui eu
poderia jogar os arquivos se esse
arquivo for maior né como eu vou mostrar
aqui para vocês ó e outra coisa
interessante do Google é que o Google é
capaz de processar áudios e vídeos ou
seja você não precisa nem transcrever
eles Você pode baixar o vídeo e jogar
inteiro aqui pro Google ele vai
processar só que olha só quantos tokens
esse vídeo aqui de 1 hora vou tirar aqui
deixar do meu lado desse ladinho aqui
meu vídeo olha só vou dar um zoom aqui
para você ver esse vídeo aqui ó o Google
processou de mni processou e deve ele tá
trazendo
831.18 aconteceu quando a bola caiu e se
tiver uma bola ali a bola tiver caindo
ele vai me dizer o que tava acontecendo
naquele momento Ah ele processa tudo
então tu imagina que 800.000 tokens eu
não consigo utilizar isso por exemplo
chpt ele nem tem essa capacidade para
processar vídeo e é por isso que eu não
vou mandar vídeos para cá porque se eu
mandar vídeos diretamente pro Jeni eu
vou usar muito da memória dele já lá de
contexto pensa assim como se fosse uma
memória RAM Então você tem um espaço ali
que você pode utilizar memória de
trabalho digamos assim se eu jogar
vários vídeos aqui eu vou ocupar demais
a min memória RAM então eu não quero
jogar vídeos eu quero jogar textos ou
áudios porque os áudios fica muito menor
vou dar um exemplo aqui ó esse esse
áudio é maior que aquele vídeo é um
vídeo que eu transformei em áudio e ele
deu 182.000 tokens então só aqui só com
esse áudio se eu pegasse esse áudio eu
tivesse jogado isso e fosse possível
jogar esse áudio dentro do chat PT
porque nem isso é possível a única coisa
que eu consigo fazer no s GPT aqui é
clicar aqui e mandar um áudio que eu tô
gravando agora or nesse momento ó eu
clico aqui ele vai processar e vai
receber esse áudio e vai processar isso
que eu mandei para ele mas eu não
consigo anexar aqui ó eu não consigo
clicar aqui e anexar um áudio eu posso
anexar aqui fotos pdfs etc Beleza então
por isso que eu quando eu preciso tratar
arquivos muito grandes e e que eu não
quero perder as informações essa janela
de contexto dele porque eu quero que por
exemplo eu quero o quê tratar minha
história então se eu penso da minha
história vai ter às vezes que eu vou
comentar num podcast sobre uma coisa
outro podcast na outra eu poderia pedir
para ele jogar as histórias aqui pedindo
para ele sempre transcrever a minha
história e eu ir pedindo sempre para ele
pegar esse esse resumo da história e
jogar pro próximo episódio e tratar e
adicionar mas a gente vai perder muitas
nuances Além disso alguns Episódios vão
superar mais de 200.000 tokens porque
tem episódios aqui que tem 4 horas de
duração por isso a escolha é o jemeni
toda vez que eu preciso tratar arquivos
muito muito grandes eu escolho ele e eu
vou te dizer ele tá cada vez melhor a
essa aidade essa essa competição Essa
corrida para chegar em agi tá fazendo
com que as empresas invistam bilhões e
bilhões de dólares e evoluam rapidamente
para não ficar para trás e quem são os
beneficiados nisso pelo menos por
enquanto somos nós que podemos utilizar
como é o caso do Google aqui de graça
isso mesmo que tô falando é de graça
utilizar o Google através dessa URL que
eu vou deixar inclusive aqui que é aist
studio.google.com
beleza expliquei o que eu vou fazer E aí
Alan Qual que é o primeiro passo antes
de começar fazer aqui pegar todas as
referências tratar os dados eu quero eu
gosto sempre refletir sobre as minhas
ações né Então nada mais justo do que
utilizar o meu segundo célebro para isso
então inclusive daqui que eu vou tirar
muitas das informações para poder
extrair a minha história o segundo
célebro se você não sabe o que é eu
tenho vídeos aqui no YouTube eu vou
deixar também um vídeo aqui embaixo para
você clicar e poder assistir e criar o
seu eu ensino como criar aqui um segundo
cérebro com inem a como esse aqui que
você tá vendo o ponto é por que que eu
vou começar com ele porque eu vou
começar escrevendo então ó extrair a
minha
história com o
ia novamente
al que que eu gosto de pensar primeira
coisa que eu gosto de pensar é Qual
modelo eu vou usar porque Com base no
modelo eu tenho que entender as
limitações do modelo e que eu quero
daquele modelo eu poderia fazer isso com
chat PT vamos botar aqui PT é uma opção
ah janela a janela é de
apenas de
apenas 128k tokens como eu falei
já e isso às vezes um vídeo meu inteiro
já vai cobrir e outra coisa é que ele
tem problema em tratar conteúdos longos
eu tô falando de chat PT
4oo porque quando vou falar eu pago para
usar o chat chpt mais caro de todos que
é o chat PT
o1 e esse chat PT o mais caro de todos
né que é o o o1 ele tem uma coisa
interessante que é ele consegue
trabalhar até melhor que o cloud com
conteúdos de longos conteúdos que tem
muita informação Claro que dentro dos
seus 128.000 tokens al o que que tu quer
dizer aqui eu quero dizer que pensa como
se tivesse qualidade também das memórias
então tu tem ade ó Existe existe o
tamanho da memória eu tô dizendo memória
aqui para ficar mais fácil que as
pessoas conhecem memória R computador
mas quando eu falo aqui de est falando
de janela de contexto que são os tokens
a unidade de medida menor possível que
oá trabalha então eu tenho tamanho e
qualidade na janela de
contexto a qualidade do
gem ela é inferior ao Cloud que é
inferior ao o1 o chat GPT o GPT o1
né a
qualidade agora quando a gente vai falar
de capacidade né de
tamanho Opa escrevi errado aqui era
assim
ó quando a gente vai falar de cidade é a
mesma mesma cobrinha aqui só que ao
contrário né demai Ele é maior que o
cloud e o clod é maior que a
1 então quando eu preciso tratar
informações que tenam menos de 100.000
tokens por aí 110.000 tokens mas que eu
preciso da atenção da ia com mais
qualidade eu vou pro o1 pro aqui o pro
né o1 pro
quando eu preciso de qualidade e tamanho
maior que 128.000 tokens que seja menor
que 200.000 e de preferência também que
ela entenda mais as nuances de
comunicação eu vou pro Cloud quando eu
preciso de muita informação e eu não
quero perder essas nuances mesmo que a
capacidade a qualidade dessa capacidade
não não seja tão boa eu vou pro gemeni
Então nesse caso eu quero estrear minha
história a minha história ela tá
dividida em em mais de 20 em 23
Episódios do podcast área ah em inúmeras
entrevistas do meu podcast em inúmeras
lives que eu fiz em inúmeras informações
e conteúdos diversos e existe mais aqui
uma limitação o cloud até o momento que
eu gravo esse vídeo ele permite que eu
mande no máximo 20
arquivos só de episódios do meu podcast
Eu tenho 23 então o cloud eu não posso
utilizar o o1 tu pode utilizar eu
poderia ele ele fazendo a transcrição e
e criando ali né pontos da minha
história mas eu perderia tudo que eu
falei nos Episódios eu não conseguia
fazer interconexões entre as histórias e
além disso O A1 pro ele é extremamente
demorado então cada pergunta que eu faço
para ele demora às vezes 5 minutos e eu
não não não quero ficar 5 minutos
esperando para ele tratar cada um dos
meus sei lá 40 arquivos que eu vou
tratar aqui então não não vou utilizar
nem o pro nem o clou A escolha é
de
menai e agora ah Qual modelo de menai
existem vários eu vou mostrar para vocês
também é de menai por causa dos 2
milhões de tokens Então qual o modelo G
menai aqui se quando eu clico aqui em
criar um novo prompt eu tenho uma
barrinha aqui lateral deixa eu dar um
zoom nela aqui também essa Barrinha aqui
ó já tá me falando que tem 2 milhões de
token ou gemeni
experimental 1206 esse aqui eu já olhei
algumas notícias dele e ele é o que tá
tendo uma nota de pela avaliação né da
das pessoas que estudam muito esse
mercado muito acima inclusive do 2.0
então é a minha escolha vai ser o
1206 é o que eu tenho mais utilizado
aqui tem outro interessante aqui para
quem for testar que é o Jeni Flash
Thinking experimental aqui por que que
que que é interessante ter esse cara
aqui ele Ó a janela de contexto dele
aqui ó é 32.000 tokens só então é
pequeninho só que ele tem uma capacidade
de fazer reasoning né como o A1 pro como
o de psic V3 também tem uma capacidade
ali De reasoning que se tu apertar o
botãozinho dele lá e é bem interessante
Eu Fiz alguns testes aqui e é bem bem
interessante e ele é muito mais rápido
inclusive Claro muito mais rápido que o
A1 porque ele é no modelo muito menor né
ele tá no flash flash se eu não me
engano é um modelo de 8 a 16 bilhões de
tokens então é um modelo bem menor
Beleza então aqui tá a explicação para
vocês por que eu vou usar o di menai por
que que eu acho importante te explicar
isso esse esse esse é minha
racionalização por trás para não
simplesmente dizer assim ó usa tal
Porque não é muito tem muito mais
nuances do que isso você precisa
entender sim sobre lms você não precisa
entender como funciona um Transformer
como funciona a
tokenização como é que é o processo de
ah a criação de um modelo mas é
importante você entender as features
para poder utilizar bem É como se você
fosse comprar um carro por exemplo você
não precisa entender de engen Aria de um
motor mas você precisa entender as
features daquele carro para você poder
comprar o carro que mais combina com
você ou que você mais precisa naquele
momento a mesma coisa aqui a gente
precisa entender essas informações dito
isso vamos agora a escolha o dimai vai
ser o dimai
e como como Vou
extrair eu poderia enviar os vídeos
baixar os vídeos e mandar pro jemai só
que como vocês viram isso vai usar muito
mais n de contexto do que eu preciso
então eu preciso extrair os áudios os
textos dos podcasts etc que eu fui
entrevistado ou que ou que eu participei
Existem várias formas de fazer isso eu
vou mostrar mais fácil aqui para
vocês então aqui eu já deixei aberto né
Aqui tem vários episódios que eu eu
entrevistei fui entrevistado eu até
pensei em usar eles mas seria muito
conteúdo então eu separei aqui os
episódios que eu fui entrevistado em
canais ou lives que eu dei e eu poderia
fazer isso de algumas formas eu poderia
por exemplo utilizar o
assembly que é na minha visão de longe a
melhor ferramenta a melhor ia de
transcrição de áudio ela até pouco tempo
atrás você podia mandar um vídeo do
YouTube ele transcrevia para você hoje
vamos ver aqui ó tem o playground ó no
playground Eu só consigo fazer isso
mandando áudios Agora eu tenho que
selecionar o arquivo ó eu preciso mandar
o áudio para cá ou seja deixa eu ver
stream não posso falar e ela vai
transcrever ou eu posso vir aqui
selecionar o áudio e fazer o upload do
áudio então não tem mais a opção de
transcrever diretamente do YouTube mas
ela é de longe a melhor ferramenta para
fazer isso AL como é que você utiliza
ela você pega aqui e manda o áudio não
eu utilizo ela via código Aqui tá o meu
código Esse é código que eu escrevi para
transcrever os meus vídeos que eu tinha
no meu computador então ah como é que tu
fez isso eu simplesmente pedir pro Cloud
Ai que para mim na área de programação é
a melhor LM então assim mais uma coisa
aqui eu vou escrever para você também
nesse vídeo então quando eu
preciso eu preciso
programar eu uso
Cloud E se o problema é o Son 3.5 porque
tem mais isso não adianta né Qualquer
Cloud eu uso 3.5 Ah e se se o código for
muito difícil se for algo muito
difícil
então eu uso o chat PT o1
pro novamente é por isso que tá
importante vocês entenderem e não só
entenderem e testarem ah os poder dessas
llms porque cada uma vai sair melhor
para uma coisa quando eu preciso
escrever um código rápido eu uso o cloud
quando eu quero usar o cloud lendo ainda
dos meus arquivos eu uso uma ferramenta
chamado cursor que vai ler todo o meus
meus códigos e vai conseguir criar nesse
nesse caso eu vim aqui Criei um código
com o cloud Ah que transcreve para mim
os conteúdos e simplesmente rodei ele
aqui ó dentro do meu terminal e o que
que ele fez com isso Ele criou Ele criou
uma transcrição inteira para mim essa
transcrição tá aqui
ó em vídeos e tá aqui a transcrição
corrida de ratos tá aqui a transcrição
inteira do meu conteúdo dessa Live que
eu dei e de uma forma assim nem
comparação do Whisper com o assembly
assembly consegue extrair as nuances
muito melhor sem errar as palavras e
tudo mais ele é muito muito melhor não é
à toa se você for ver aqui a minha
planilha de custos né Ele é mais caro
que o Whisper ó o Whisper custa 11
centavos de dólar à hora enquanto o
assembly custa 36 centavos de dólar à
hora a gente tá falando aí de um pouco
mais de três vezes mais caro mas pensa
36 centavos de dólar a hora para
transcrever cada hora ou seja uma hora
me custou aí ah sei lá r$ 3
por aí para transcrever um conteúdo
inteiro menos ainda né R 1,50 r$ 80 para
transcrever uma hora de conteúdo quanto
seria para eu pagar para alguém
transcrever um conteúdo para mim e
provavelmente teria erros e aqui ela
transcreve de uma forma perfeita Então
qual que é a forma de de mandar esses
conteúdos para o ji eu vou mandar eles
por texto Então eu vou escrever aqui
também por ela gosta de escrever isso
normalmente ISO acontece diretamente na
minha cabeça só que aqui eu tô
escrevendo para você entender o que
acontece na minha cabeça para criar e
para poder testar e para poder utilizar
o llm então vou enviar como
extrair enviar os textos pro gni para
por qu Por uma questão de velocidade
cada vez que eu vou mandar um áudio ele
vai ter que processar o áudio Demora um
tempão ó por uma questão de velocidade e
economia de tokens Porque por mais que
eu tenho 2 milhões de eu tenho muito
conteúdo para mandar para ele e eu quero
que todo o conteúdo esteja na janela de
contexto dele enquanto ele ainda
processa para mim para extrair isso para
mim beleza como vai ser feito isso vamos
primeira parte é extrair o que uma forma
que você tem bem simples de extrair é
utilizando um plugin que eu já mostrei
aqui no canal e eu vou mostrar de novo
para que você ah possa utilizá-lo eu vou
também deixar o link dele aqui embaixo
que é o YouTube subtitle subtitle da
load helper esse cara aqui ele vai te
ajudar com basicamente um clique você
clica aqui você pode clicar aqui em TXT
ele vai gerar a transcrição que foi
gerada pelo YouTube você vai baixar
cliquei aqui baixou transcrição É pode
ser em csv pode ser em TXT pode ser em
qualquer um deles o problema de baixando
em TXT que ele não tá mais salvando como
TXT você vai ter que editar o arquivo
depois vou baixar em csv aqui csv ele
vem a marcação né de que minuto vou
abrir aqui para você ver de que minuto
aquilo foi
salvo vou abrir aqui minha pasta
ó cliquei aqui para você
ver ele salva assim
ó o minuto que foi falado o segundo e o
que foi falado a gente tá falando que
vai gastar mais tokens também aqui ó tá
vendo ele vai gastar tokens de forma
desnecessária também aqui com horários
eu não quero isso eu quero o conteúdo
realmente tratado da melhor forma
possível então vou baixar realmente só
em Tex Então vou vir aqui primeira coisa
que eu vou fazer vai ser clicar aqui
baixar
os conteúdos existem formas diferentes
de fazer isso tá eu tô mostrando a forma
mais simples para pessoas aqui que estão
me assistindo conseguir já poderem fazer
isso eu poderia fazer isso via pi do
gemeni onde eu vou pegar e fazer uma I
ficar buscando quais podcasts me
entrevistaram L lá mas existem coisas
que são mais rápidas fazer aqui de forma
manual do que simplesmente parar inteiro
para criar uma automação que vai ser
usado só uma vez eu paro para criar
automações quando isso vai essa
automação pode ser utilizada várias e
várias vezes então aqui beleza baixei e
outra dica que eu dou também para quem
gosta de automatizar bastante é faça
manualmente a primeira vez e depois você
processa isso com o ia porque o humano
do looping ele é importante para
inclusive identificar falhas ou
identificar alguns padrões que devem ser
feitos então o que que eu tô fazendo
aqui basicamente eu tô entrando Episódio
por Episódio clicando aqui no meu
addon E clicando no botão aqui TXT e
download então aqui já tá baixando todas
elas ó todas as transcrições todos
podcast que eu
participei e é isso esses aqui eu não
vou baixar ótimo o que que eu tenho que
fazer agora eu vou separar eles uma
pasta todos aqui
ó vou criar uma pasta aqui no meu
desktop transcrições
Vou salvar elas aqui
pronto eu vou ver se o gmen já vai
conseguir ler elas mesmo que elas não
estão com o final pon TXT Então vou vir
abrir aqui vou tentar mandar para ele
uma dessas aqui
upload mesa transcrições e vou clicar
aqui ó ele diz que não suporta esse tipo
de arquivo então vou fazer manualmente
aqui vou colocar o ponto txc no
final pon
TXT pon XT tô quase escrevendo script em
Python que vai ia pegar E ler todos
esses arquivos aqui transformar todos
eles em
TXT além desses arquivos esse aqui eu
vou excluir que é o csv né que tem muita
informação ali desnecessária txt
TXT
TXT Eu também Criei um script que eu
poderia mandar os links desses YouTubes
ele ia usar o assembly ia transcrever de
uma forma muito boa ah só que isso eu
teria que parar tudo mostrar para vocês
como o código funciona e tudo mais eu
resolvi fazer dessa forma aqui porque
qualquer pessoa que tá assistindo esse
vídeo consegue fazer né o que eu fiz
aqui basicamente foi clicar em baixar e
só botei ponto XT aqui para o Google
conseguir ler agora que eu vou fazer eu
vou subir esses arquivos inteiros todos
eles aqui no
Google são ó oito arquivos inteiros ele
vai calcular ó quantos ó quantos tokens
cada um tem então ele já utilizou aqui ó
só com esses
arquivos
342.000 tokens ou seja isso não cabe
dentro do o vamos ver
lá isso não vai caber dentro do GPT 4
não vai caber dentro do Cloud não vai só
caberia dentro do g o deeps né ele tem
64k de janela de contexto ele também não
caberia Ele ficaria aqui atrás do shot
GT4 então vocês estão vendo aqui que
nesses casos faz todo tal sentido
utilizar o dimen que mais que eu tenho
aqui lembra eu transcrevi aqui eu tinha
dois vídeos no meu computador eu
utilizei meu script em Python e fiz a
transcrição deles que são duas lives que
eu dei eu vou botas aqui também vamos
ver quanto vai aumentar agora tá com
342.000 deu foi para 380.000 tokens que
mais eu ainda tenho os meus podcasts eu
vou ver eu nunca mandei tanto arquivo
assim ao mesmo tempo para ele eu vou
pegar aqui agora os meus podcasts eu até
separei eles aqui também então aqui ó em
Episódio vi
lendária Deixa eu ver se eu vou
selecionar todos eles e mandar todos de
uma
vez ele aceitou então eu sinceramente eu
desconheço o limite do quanto que o
dimen aceita porque toda vez que eu
mando arquivos para ele ele sempre vai
aceitando aceitando aceitando Ele parece
um buraco negro tipo não não tem fim
Olha só eu joguei todos os meus agora os
meus episódios vida lendária nele também
porque aqui também tem sobre minha
história e ele ficou com
492.000 tokens novamente a única a a
única empresa que eu conheço que tem
essa capacidade das grandes empresas né
é o Google é o Jeni no 1.5 ele tem 2
milhões também no 1.5 Flash ele tem 1
milhão de tokens e eu vou utilizar o Jen
experimental o 1206 que a princípio né
Por pelos testes que eu já fiz e todo
mundo me falou e eu também fiz e Gostei
ele é o maior a gente tem aqui o jemi
2.0 Flash o experim 1206 e depois a
gente tem 1.5 pro experiment Tá ok e que
acontece mas por que que tu não vai
utilizar o 2.0 Flash experiment e tá
usando esse 206 porque aqui ó vamos
olhar aqui ó ó o flash experimental ele
tem 128.000 tokens e outra coisa ele
como ele é flash toda toda a linha flash
do Google é uma linha que é uma llm
menor ou seja ela tem menos pesos ela
tem menos nódulos de modelo do modelo
ali dentro e isso faz o quê faz com que
ela tenha uma capacidade de raciocínio
de capacidade de inteligência menor
então o flash é interessante para coisas
mais simples mais rápidas mesmo como eu
quero extrair olha só essa ela vai ter
que entender a nuance de tudo que foi
falado aqui e extrair a minha história
então é algo muito complexo ser feito
por isso eu vou utilizar o 1206 que a
princípio é a melhor eu já fiz muito
testes nessas e eu sei que é assim se eu
fosse querer algo muito uma nuance muito
específica e conseguisse interconectar
todas as ideias o o1 seria melhor para
isso só que o o1 Além de demorado ele
também
eh só tem 128.000 tokens Não adiantaria
então Bora lá qual que é o próximo passo
né extrair eu preciso de um prompt agora
o próximo passo aqui depois de extrair
eu preciso do um prompt botar aqui uma
observação aqui
ó no meio desse
conteúdo preciso de um prompt
agora não preciso programar depois
extrair preciso do prompt como fazer
esse prompt eu poderia simplesmente
escrever encontre aqui quais são eu
quero eu quero minha história de forma
cronológica esses conteúdos são ah
Episódios do meu podcast ou entrevistas
comigo onde eu conto um pouco da minha
entrevista da minha da minha experiência
o ideal agora pensando né os podcasts
que eu fui entrevistado realmente o
ideal seria eu ter transcrito eles com o
assembly porque ele consegue pegar Quem
que é o interlocutor ele conseguiria
separar eu da pessoa que tá me
perguntando Mas tudo bem eu vou escrever
aqui eu acho que ele vai conseguir
porque nenhum interlocutor nenhum
nenhuma pessoa que me entrevistou
ah contou muito da sua história por isso
que é importante também eu não ten
escolhido aquele meu canal aqui Alan
ncolas deixa eu abrir
aqui ver se ele tá aberto aqui o meu
canal que eu tinha mostrado para vocês
porque naquele canal Eu entrevisto
muitas pessoas então a ia se confundir
então a escolha de Qual material nós
vamos usar para extrair o conteúdo que a
gente quer é extremamente importante
vamos lá Alan como é que tu vai criar
esse prompt uma das formas que eu posso
criar esse prompt é usando o meu próprio
alenar no WhatsApp então se você não
sabe ainda vou abrir aqui meu
Whatsapp e eu posso utilizar tem uma ia
que a gente tá criou aqui me time a
gente desenvolveu uma ia que fica no
WhatsApp essa ia aqui ó vou deixar
também o link para ela nos comentários
para você poder utilizar ela e
basicamente eu vou descrever para ela o
promp que eu quero que ela crie Então
gostaria de extrair a minha
história de maneira
cronológica e
detalhada que está dentro de diversos
arquivos de entrevistas
e
entrevistas
artigos e artigos que
escrevi quero que a ia quero que a
ia
consiga ler todas as
informações e
correlacionar a história
para que a medida para que consiga me
entregar
ã de forma mais
precisa mais
precisa
possível a minha
história e vou dizer para ela também
para ela focar
focando Principalmente nos momentos de
superação A ideia é criar uma jornada do
Herói a a esse material na verdade né
esse
material terial extraído será usado
eventualmente
para
entrevistas e
também jornada
do herói em materiais de marketing por
que que eu tô falando isso aqui já para
ela porque eu quero que ela Ela entenda
o o que que ela vai extrair né então
aqui mandei né
PR me ela vai processar isso aqui e vai
me entregar outra maneira que você pode
também fazer isso é através de uma de um
chat IPT que a gente desenvolveu aqui
deixa eu ver se ele tá aqui
disponível que é
não no chat eu quero explorar tá aqui ó
criador de
prompts meta prompt tá ali ó meta prop
lendário então tem esse também vou
deixar esse também disponível aqui onde
se eu falar para ele aqui ele vai criar
para
mim dependendo do prompt eu prefiro que
seja criado pelo Cloud ou pelo gemeni ou
Thinking ou pelo próprio o1 nesse caso
aqui é um promp que é simples então eu
vou escrever aqui mesmo o Alan EA lá ó
ele recebeu já aqui vai processar ele o
Alan vai demorar um pouquinho mais para
responder que que o jpt porque ele ele
processa ele tem um tempo de espera PR
caso eu eu fique mandando mensagens
picotadas lá ele vai esperar para
processar tudo de uma vez só por isso
que eu preferi já abrir aqui e fazer
aqui rapidinho então para realizar
tarefa de forma mais eficaz vamos seguir
o passo a passo atue como biógrafo
profissional especializado narrativas
inspiradoras legal produz comentário por
favor envie os arquivos tá então beleza
vou pegar aqui vou jogar aqui e uma
coisa importante tá eu já perdi muitas
vezes
ã conversas e promes aqui inteiros que
eu tava fazendo com Jeni porque eu não
cliquei no botão salvar então aqui eu já
vou botar ó história do
Alan Vou salvar e vou e vou salvar só
que botei aqui o nome e salvei por se
você não fizer isso eu já fiz várias
vezes aqui já perdi várias e várias
várias conversas inteiras J porque eu
não tinha salvado até eu me ligar aqui
não eu tenho que salvar as conversas é
diferente de todas as outras de que
salva Automatic aqui você tem que clicar
lá em salvar então vou dar o comando
aqui né que você precisa fazer atuar
como
lá e é isso
aqui pronto bom tá vendo esse reloginho
aqui provavelmente ele vai demorar um
tempinho Então vou pedir pro meu editor
aqui acelerar o vídeo enquanto eu espero
opa deu um erro aqui no dienai deixa eu
ver o que foi um erro correu Vou tentar
de
novo outra coisa que eu gosto de fazer
também quando eu vou documentando assim
meu processo eu aconselho você a fazer
também
é salvar os prometes aqui na empresa
Inclusive a gente tem um uma um um
reservatório um repositório no github
onde a gente versiona inclusive os
nossos pretos então quando eu vou
escrevendo assim é melhor salvar pra
gente não perder eu vou clicar aqui vou
editar novamente eu nunca tinha colocado
tantos arquivos assim ao mesmo tempo
talvez eu vou fazer isso eu vou pegar e
vou jogar menos arquivos de uma vez só
senão el demorar inclusive vai demorar
muito tempo para fazer isso en quandoo
ele tá fazendo isso aqui eu vou abrir
outra janela aqui eu vou tirar esse meu
vídeo eu vou colocar esse mesmo prompt
eu vou adicionar menos arquivos e vou
rodar também vou adicionar quatro
episódios do meu
podcast extraindo deu 20.000 tokens e
bora lá ó aqui deu um erro de novo
Provavelmente o tamanho do não tá
conseguindo suportar aqui por mais que
tá dentro da janela de contexto dele é
muita informação para ele trabalhar de
uma vez só ó aqui ele conseguiu
lá o foco
consider beleza Ele tá dizendo que vai
fazer aguardando ansiosamente pelos
arquivos Então tá tá aqui os arquivos
vou mandar para ele de novo não entendu
o que eu tinha mandado pelo
jeito segue os arquivos
para
análise ó pronto para iniciar aqui está
o resumo que farei ó já li os quatro
arquivos enviados deixa eu dar um zoom
aqui a extração de informações
relevantes extrair informações sobre sua
trajetória de vida incluindo início da
gravação de conteúdo criação de Quad
visão sentimentos de não ser suficiente
do Síndrome do impostor conquistar
materiais profissionais A reflexão 2019
a identificação de padrões identificação
BL BL blá passo dois agora destaque
momento de superação os principais
momentos de superação identificados
foram l l lá contextualização ah antes
2015 dívidas e segurança falta de
clareza sobre o futuro trabalhava com
programação tinha o sonho de morar no
Canadá durante 2015 2019 foco intenso
desenvolvimento pessoal leitura de
livros depois 2019 crise exencial R
descoberto propósito blá blá blá e aqui
a linha do tempo ó an 2015 início 2017
2020 jornada do Herói e produção de um
documento detalhado agora aqui ó estou
trabalhando na escrita de uma e a quanto
tempo já demorou aqui para ele criar
isso ó mais de um minuto então eu tenho
me surpreendido assim com a ó o quanta
coisa ele tá fazendo aqui a saída também
que é um problema que a gente tem no
Cloud né vou fazer a mesma coisa no
Cloud o mesmo processo aqui eu vou
deixar aqui aberto desse lado aqui no
Cloud e vou fazer o mesmo processo no
Cloud pra gente até comparar aqui então
o cloud Lembrando aqui ó eu posso mandar
só 20 arquivos de no máximo 30 megas
cada um o que que eu faria aqui bom
talvez eu já fiz isso né Eu queria aqui
tem um Python que que pegou e comessou
eles todos em PDF
Ah só que ficou muito grande né ficou
acima do do do que do que é permitido na
janela de contexto do aqui do Cloud
Então vou pegar vou pegar lá o meu
prompt
copiar aqui do próprio dem
menai copiar vou colar
aqui e vamos processar para ver o que
vai
acontecer a mesma coisa poderia fazer
aqui com 1 pro a maioria das pessoas não
tem o A1 pro não faz sentido daí eu tá
testando o A1 pro junto então aqui ele
já pegou os Marcos e vamos lá vamos
continuar aqui ele terminou ó ele já fez
a produção detalhada estruturei a
biografia de de forma aqui ele tá est
biografia né as datas e tal o que
aconteceu e agora eu vou passar para ele
mais
arquivos continue agora
ah
melhorando e
incluindo novas
informações sobre minha jornada e
timeline com base nos arquivos em
em anexo Então vou mandar para ele agora
mais arquivos né eu tinha mandado até o
quatro vou mandar até o 10
agora vamos ver como é que ele vai
funcionar depois eu quero mandar todos
de uma vez todo o restante de uma vez
Lembrando que só isso no aqui no Cloud
já vai impedir já não vai conseguir eu
não vou conseguir mandar todos os
arquivos porque são 20 arquivos que eu
posso mandar aqui clou aqui ele me
trouxe o cloue ó eu diria que mais
detalhado se for vamos observar aqui ó o
resultado né eu tenho aqui ó a linha do
tempo a jornada do Herói e ele me trouxe
mais reasoning né tipo assim mais a o
que que ele tá pensando por trás ali mas
ele não me trouxe tanto o que o cloue
aqui me trouxe ó principais Marcos
identificados temas centrais recorrentes
narrativa cronológica aqui ó pré 2015 o
ponto de partida qual a situação minha
10.000 negativo no cheque especial
mensalmente 2015 ano da transformação
2015 2017 período de crescimento 2017
consolidação 2020 19 momento de reflexão
ele me trouxe aqui os momentos e tá mais
detalhado se a gente for observar do que
ele trouxe aqui
ó agora vou fazer a mesma coisa para ele
eu vou jogar aqui ó e a gente pode ver
aqui com esses arquivos já deu 126.000
tokens melhorou aqui ó se eu for olhar
aqui o que que ele fez ó ele já
conseguiu criar para mim na infância as
14 anos adolescência jovem adulto me
trouxe bem mais informações de men agora
vamos fazer a mesma coisa eu vou pegar
aqui jogar para ele até o
10 e uma coisa que você vão perceber é
que além dos arquivos né da limitação de
arquivos o cloud ele vai ficar sem
memória né mais rápido rapidamente do
que o J até porque a gente tá
trabalhando com 600.000 tokens e o CL só
tem 200
meu perfeito agora o que eu vou fazer
enquanto ele tá processando aqui ó aqui
deu 90 segundos ou seja 1 minuto e meio
processando e eu vou pegar agora e vou
jogar o restante do Episódio 11 até o
Episódio
13 e vou dar o mesmo comando continue
agora melhorando incluindo novas
informações sobre minha jornada e
timeline com base nos arquivos eem
anexo terminou de processar joguei aqui
para ele aqui também né melhorou os anos
90 primeiros anos Origin M bairro cab
setor 6 L
lá deixa eu pegar aqui agora jogar o
restante dos arquivos e aqui
provavelmente a gente já vai ver a falha
do Cloud onde ele não vai permitir que
eu mande todos os
arquivos ó então ele tá me dizendo o que
aqui ó que eu tô ultrapassando em 44%
Ah o limite que eles tê né de de tokens
e também passando o limite de arquivos
permitidos então eu vou remover aqui
alguns e ver se eu consigo
mandar ainda 3% Beleza consegui mandar
até o até o
14 vou dar o OK aqui e já deu erro de
novo deu erro de novo vou ter que tirar
mais
consegui até o
13 ele tá agora processando vamos ver o
que que ele fez aqui então enquanto o
clou tá pedindo arrego aqui ó dando erro
e tudo mais a gente tem
aqui o demai sorrindo e de boa
trabalhando e ele gastou só 10% do
potencial dele aqui ó 256.000 né de 2
milhões um pouquinho mais de de
10% vamos lá agora eu já mandei todos os
arquivos para ele ele já conseguiu
extrair de tudo aqui tá minha história
extraiu de tudo e eu vou mandar para ele
agora ainda os podcasts continua aqui
trabalhando né eu vou mandar para ele
agora os meus podcast que foram
extraídos lá em transcrições mandar para
ele esses aqui
todos eu vou mandar antes de mandar isso
aqui para ele eu vou mandar os vídeos
que foram transcritos porque são vídeos
individuais Então vou jogar aqui
continue
agora vou jogar esses dois aqui por que
ela porque lá nas entrevistas são duas
pessoas falando de eu vou explicar para
ele que essas aqui são entrevistas que
vai ter uma pessoa que tá fazendo
perguntas para mim para ele identificar
que as respostas que eu estou dando e
extrair das respostas que eu estou dando
e não das perguntas que foram feitas Ah
não pela história do do interlocutor né
da pessoa que tá fazendo as perguntas
Então bora lá vou rodar aqui não adianta
mais eu tentar rodar nada no clou Ele
usou toda a memória que ele conseguiu
iia ele conseguiu extrair isso aqui o
que eu posso fazer talvez é pegar aqui
ó essa história aqui se bem que aqui tá
mais que acontece se eu pegar essa
história jogar para ele para ele
identificar o que que faltou eu consegui
jogar mais arquivos no ji então nem vai
adiantar minha ideia era jogar aqui a o
que que o J me trouxe para que o clou
pudesse analisar e falar o que que qual
a diferença deu né Mas Não adiantaria
Não adiantaria fazer nada disso aqui
então beleza deixa eu ver aqui ele tá
processando agora tem mais dois arquivos
bem grandes são duas lives que eu fiz
cada uma ali com cerca de 2 horas e
pouco as duas somadas ele vai analisar
duas lives que eu fiz também e vai
trazer toda juntando né todas as
histórias para que possa minha timeline
ficar completa Então já tenho aqui ó nos
anos 2014
2 2014 Antes 2014 né a na infância aos 5
anos jovem 14 anos jovem adulto início
da carreira fase de experimentação 21
anos e eu vou jogar para ele aqui também
depois é esse aqui ele tem aqui dos anos
90 e tudo mais né 2005 2007 período de
Formação Inicial e ele tá processando
aqui então vocês podem observar
que é porque a importância né de
entender aqui o tamanho das llms como
elas funcionam e como é que a gente pode
extrair o máximo delas Porque como você
viu ali o cloud que é uma ferramenta que
eu adoro usar o cloud é o que eu uso
mais criação de textos pra criação de
Copy pra criação de códigos de forma
geral eu gosto mais de utilizar o
cloud mesmo ele mesmo assim ele tem
limitações limitações de tamanho de
arquivo de tokens de quantidade de
arquivos que eu posso mandar eu até
agora não consegui encontrar a
quantidade de arquivos que eu posso
mandar pro jmi Eu já mandei mais de 40
50 arquivos em uma conversa só só então
é algo que trans trans ultrapassa
tranquilamente né qualquer outra outra
ia vamos ver o que ele me retornou aqui
ele tá me retornando agora todo o
conteúdo aqui
ó atualizado com
base no que eu já tinha falado para ele
com base nesses novos conteúdos que eu
posso notar é para ver se ele verificar
se ele esqueceu se ele perdeu alguma
coisa mas pelo que eu tô vendo não ó ele
tá botando datas novas ó 2011 2012 2013
2014 2015
2017 2018 2019 tá quebrando ainda mais
as datas e trazendo cada vez mais
informações ou seja reaproveitando tudo
então bom consegui extrair daqui agora
tu imagina o seguinte eu estrai daqui a
minha história só que eu poderia Agora
eu tenho na memória
dele
bom são cerca de 50 horas de conteúdo eu
poderia extrair desses 50 horas de
conteúdo quanta coisa poderia extrair
conteúdo sobre a que eu falei conteúdos
sobre marketing que eu já falei aqui
também eu poderia criar uma esteira
infinita de conteúdo aqui e até mesmo de
criação de produtos baseado em tudo que
eu falei agora você imagina o seguinte
você poderia pegar canais inteiros do
YouTube que você deseja estudar Você
poderia pegar um canal inteiro de um
podcast que você gosta de escutar por
exemplo
e extrair Quais foram os maiores
insights quais são o que que de comum
existe na história da das pessoas por
exemplo que passaram por aquele Episódio
O que que existe ah de ensinamentos por
exemplo se você pega um um podcast como
vurb mesmo lá que passa muitos
copywriters por ele que é uma coisa que
eu até pretendo fazer Ah imagina você
pegar os melhores copywriters que foram
entrevistados no vtb você jogar aqui e
você conseguir extrair Qual é o qual é o
tipo de modelo de que eles que eles têm
lá de de criação de Copy de visão
estratégica para cresc
crescer nas vendas aumentar as vendas e
conseguir atingir mais clientes Então as
formas que a gente pode utilizar uma
ferramenta como essa aqui que eu acabei
de apresentar são inúmeras eu utilizei
para quê
Sinceramente esse vídeo aqui ficou com
aí cerca de 50 minutos 1 hora boa parte
de do momento que eu tava aqui fazendo
foi explicando para vocês se eu tivesse
só parado e focado em fazer eu acho que
eu deveria ter feito isso aqui sei lá em
5 ou 10 minutos e com base nisso isso em
5 10 minutos eu teria extraído aqui ó
como você tá vendo toda a minha história
desde a minha infância contando aqui
coisas onde é que eu cresci o que
aconteceu quando eu era criança todos os
pontos da minha vida estão aqui não só
isso ele conseguiu conectar isso criando
aqui uma jornada detalhada dos momentos
de superação Então olha só origem
humilde dificuldades financeiras na
infância busca por um propósito de
autoconhecimento a transição de uma
mentalidade focada em dinheiro L lá
superação da s do impostor o sentimento
de não ser bom suficiente Conquista
independência financeira domínio da arte
da arte de morrer reconhecimento da
citação da própria generalidade
desenvolvimento da filosofia inen
socialista confronto com ideologias
entendimento de poder de perguntas e
aqui tá vindo um monte ou seja poderia
pegar para ele vou fazer esse teste aqui
ó
ã conte agora a minha história de
superação
agora com base em tudo o que você agora
sabe sobre mim Alan ncolas me conte a
minha
história de superação da origem 1000 e
dificuldades financeiras
Ah com uma
estratégia
de jornada do
Herói com uma pitada
de Los Plus twist no
final vamos ver o que ele vai fazer né
ela é muito boa Mas como eu falei para
textos não tão boa quanto o clou Então
imagina eu nem sei eu vou ver o que vai
acontecer aqui agora mas imagina que eu
posso pegar essas detalhes né esses
momentos de superação a integração com
de novos arquivos não sei o que lá posso
pegar várias informações que eu tenho
aqui e conseguir se eu ainda salvo esse
esse
Ah isso de uma maneira que minha equipe
possa ter acesso fazer perguntas Ah eu
quero criar um conteúdo de Dia dos Pais
pro Alan o que que ele já falou nas
redes sociais imagina que se eu pego e
começo a alimentar uma Iá dessa com tudo
que eu comento dos meus no meu Instagram
no meus Stories ah com tudo que eu falo
em todos os vídeos do meu YouTube com
tudo que eu falei em várias entrevistas
e meu time consegue produzir daí
conteúdos infinitos Ou nem mesmo meu
time umaa que fique ali criando
conteúdos entendendo que as pessoas
enganjar aquilo que aconteceu comigo e
se eu linkar então ainda o Jeni consegue
fazer isso ele consegue analisar fotos
eu mandar fotos para ele com data e ele
conectar essas essas essas essas datas
com as minhas fotos e inclusive talvez
criar conteúdos já um Carrossel pro
Instagram para mostrar um pouquinho a
minha história e aí por aí vai então o
que nós temos em mãos aqui é algo que
nos possibilita criar conteúdos
infinitos você só precisa saber o que
aqui para usar ele saber que agora você
sabe que ele consegue lidar com tanta
informação saber como mandar arquivos e
você sabe como baixar agora transcrições
de vídeos do YouTube Inclusive eu vou
mandar aqui agora as transcrições para
ele também h e é isso é isso basicamente
é isso eu vou continuar meu trabalho
aqui eu quero agora enviar para ele
todas as transcrições do meu YouTube
depois eu quero testar e fazer várias
perguntas como essa que eu acabei de
fazer onde eu pedi para ele criar Olha
só saga do Alan do vale das sombras da
alquimia das sombras a alquimia digital
nascido no bairro marcado pela escassez
e pela violência o jovem Alon já
carregava em seus olhos curiosos a chama
de de um futuro diferente não era o
futuro de luxo sentação mas o futuro de
significado futuro onde pudesse colocar
o mundo com a essência de sua alma aos
14 anos em meio a um cotidiano que
podava sonhos ele deu os primeiros
passos em direção ao desconhecido
trabalhando como audiovisual seduzido
pelas luzes e cores que contestavam a
rigidez da sua realidade mas a música Ah
a música Essa era uma chama que argia em
seu peito Um chamado que ele não podia
ignorar recusa do chamado a múscul levou
a carar na igreja mas o eco de sua
paixão se chocava com a Dura realidade o
dinheiro era escasso a cada nota tocada
crescia angústia de não poder prover
para si e para sua amada a pobreza
sussurrava em seu ouvido tentando
convencê-lo de que a música era um sonho
ão o luxo que ele não podia cidar
empregos surgiram tentadores em sua
promessa de estabilidade mas distante da
Melodia que L anava compor sua vida
Caraca tá muito bom isso aqui em meio
cruzilhada um ofício um oficial das da
Força Aérea e um noto que parecia
rejeição plantou a primeira semente da
verdadeira transformação ao reprová-la
para o serviço militar ele o aconselhou
a seguir outro caminho naquele momento
foi um golpe uma ferida no orgulho mas o
tempo sábio Maestro revelaria que aquele
não era na verdade um siga por aqui mas
mais tarde o mentor Improvável afundado
em suas próprias ilusões plantaria outra
semente a desconfiança como mantra um
veneno que Alan em sua sabedoria
emergente recusaria beber olha só e
claro isso aqui tá muito poético tá
muito muito
ah como é que eu vou dizer né Muito mais
na de uma forma muito mais simbólica só
que isso foi o comando que eu dei para
ele eu só simplesmente pedi para ele
escrever uma jornada do Herói com pl
twice no final aqui ó PL twice É e aqui
todos esperavam que a história
terminasse com Alan Conquistando o mundo
se tornando um guru aclamado e revira a
volta Alon percebe que a verdadeira
Vitória não está em vencer o jogo do
sistema mas em transcender o próprio
jogo ele entende que a busca incessante
por sucesso reconhecido e validação
externa é uma armadilha ilusão
perpetuada pela sociedade que valoriza o
ter indem Detento do ser Alan decide
então usar sua plataforma não para sear
mais inflador digital mas inspirar
outros a questionarem o sistema e se
libertarem das amarras da Matrix e
seguirem seus próprios sonhos eles se
tornam um antig guru um provocador um
semeador de dúvidas seu objetivo não é
mais acumular seguidores mas sim
Despertar a singularidade em cada um ele
percebe que a verdadeira revolução não é
externa mas sim interna que a verdadeira
transformação não acontece no palco mas
nos bastidores da mente e assim a saga
de al continua não como uma história de
conquista linear mas com uma espiral
ascendente de autodescoberta um convite
para que cada um de nós se torne um
herói de sua própria jornada um herói
que ousa questionar que ousa ser
diferente que ousa viver uma vida
lendária e não pelos padrões do mundo
mas pelos padrões de sua própria alma
Olha só Ah e gente como eu falei né o
prompt aqui foi eu escrevi agora uma
coisa super simples e ele me trouxe algo
que já ficou bem legal se eu peço para
ele transcrever mais detalhes para ele
utilizar as pal palavras que eu utilizei
durante os episódios ou durante as
entrevistas eu peço para ele Ah se
aprofundar numa determinada história que
aconteceu comigo ele vai conseguir fazer
porque ele tem isso agora inteiro na
memória e por mais que eu tenha mandado
um monte de informação para ele eu só
gastei 300.000 tokens de 2 milhões então
se você gostou desse tipo de conteúdo
mais longo desse tipo de conteúdo mais
denso sobre o a utilização como eu uso e
a no meu dia a dia já se inscreve no
canal esse ano começa com muita novidade
aqui eu quero trazer para vocês um
conteúdo que eu não vou falar agora mas
que vocês vão gostar
bastante e também deixa aquele
comentário você já tá utilizando geminii
já utilizava ele Qual que é a ia que
você mais usa e por você usa Se a gente
pudesse ajudar aqui todo mundo que está
nesse mercado ah compartilhando um
pouquinho de como utiliza como eu acabei
de fazer com certeza nós todos vamos
começar evoluir mais rápido então se
você já utiliza as llms de uma maneira
um pouco mais avançada diga aqui qual
você utiliza para que que você utiliza
vamos te ajudar e eu te vejo no próximo
vídeo